hey guys my name is Jess I'm Dan and
here's what's been happening in gaming
today you're running off me I'm starting
do this now yeah everyone do it
sad news for fans of cats enter
gravity-defying as Sony have announced
they will be shutting off the online
services for gravity rush - as of
January next year Sony Interactive
Entertainment Japan Asia announced that
as of January 19 2018 the games online
services will be shut down just a year
after it launched if you're wondering
what you'll no longer be able to access
those features include rankings sending
and receiving challenges treasure hunts
and photo ghosts and dusty token
acquisition and rewards as a thank you
to players Sony are increasing the rate
of dusty tokens as part of an event that
will last until the online services are
shut down so be sure to check that up
Neha Red Dead Redemption tuned has got a
new trailer so I want to show that works
but if you are avoiding spoilers you
might want to skip this one the new
trailer gives us a look at the game's
protagonist arthur Morgan who's punked
of the Vandal em gang yes the same gang
you hunt down as John Marston in Red
Dead Redemption its charismatic Lee the
Dutch also looks to be making a return
so it's pretty clear this one is a
prequel according to the official
description Red Dead Redemption 2 is the
story of outlaw after Morgan and the van
der Linde gang as they rob fight and
steal their way across the vast and
rugged heart of America in order to
survive
unfortunately the trailer doesn't reveal
a release date outside of spring 2018
but you can check out the full trailer
right here on GameSpot just two seconds
you don't we haven't heard about in like
ages yeah
Skyrim oh yeah it has been like 48 hours
I think what's happening Muskaan
anything uh yeah actually it's getting a
survival mode and it's free kind of II
don't really we'll explain the new mode
which you access via creation Club makes
the game more challenging through three
main elements hunger fatigue and weather
according to Bethesda as you become
hungry your total available stamina will
decrease represented by a dark region
inside the stamina bar which will impact
your ability to use most weapons
obviously eating is the way to solve
that problem cooked foods restore your
hunger meter more than uncooked food and
if you eat enough you'll gain a bonus
called well-fed after a nice big meal
you'll need to take a nap to combat the
new fatigue elements and if you don't
take the time to take a load off the
effectiveness of your potions as well as
stamina and magic recovery will drop off
the final element whether will require
you to bundle up when it's cold other
you'll be hit with the movement speed
debuff and falling health meter the cold
will also affect your fingers as your
lock-picking ability will also decrease
there's a bunch of other elements to
this update such as diseases no health
regeneration and significantly reduced
to carry weight that you can check out
in detail over on gamespot there is some
controversy at the moment as the mode is
only free for a week once it launches
but it looks like it will then run you
about 15 bucks as you need to spend 800
creation club credits to buy it which is
50 credits more than the next lowest
increment of credits you can buy for
$7.99 so you'll have to pick up the 1500
credit pack for $14.99 so yeah the fact
that it costs 800 creation Club credits
means if you don't have the 100 credits
leftover that you get granted when you
join the program then you will have to
buy the 1500 pack which leaves you if
you only wanted this survival mode then
you have a bunch of credits left over
which is obviously the point can I spend
it on [ __ ] Armour but seems I mean
probably but that probably costs you
know another few what you have so then
that's a big problem but people a little
upset that this isn't like part of a
free up day or anything like that that
it is costing quite a bit money and the
fact that everyone who's been using mods
already on Skyrim knows that there have
been survival mode sage is accessible
for free I mean I think everyone
expected this to kind of happen with
creation Club and the advantage is you
know the whole point of creation Club
mods is they're gonna work seamlessly
like a Bethesda are assuring like every
mod is gonna work with every other mod
they're queueing it it's a whole process
they're getting money into the hands of
the devs that they're working with but
it is still money let us know what you
think about this one do you think the
price justifies the the work straight
out of the box promised the Bethesda's
bring it to creation Club that is
everything we've got for you guys today
thanks so much for joining us as always
and dirham but if you missed anything
this week we'll be back tomorrow dan
stop waiting I have so much left to say
we will be back tomorrow with the top 5
stories of the entire week let's knock a
little wave in there hey guys it is
say my name is Jeff I'm Dan and you're
about to hear what's happening in the
game you hear what's happening time
sputters it's too early
all right I don't know how time was